c'est le même cinéma et les fantômes
fait du bruit pour nos gosses booster sa
maman il masque et gilles verdez
[Applaudissements]
merci merci à vous sara lee chérie ça va
ça va bien un bébé à la série arrive
vous installez bon on va vous parler un
grand merci
qu'est ce qu'il ya sk installez vous
installez vous isabelle ça va très bien
[Musique]
c'est ce qu'a isabelle il allait être
contente d'être là c'est voulu ben c'est
un ami qui vous posez la question je
n'ai compris avec la gfa lui que mourir
de rire
il avoue mire de super bien à une
bassine will à la regarder ses modèles
avec calme et vous quelque chose mais
dit qu'aujourd'hui
et qu'est ce que je fais si momie dessus
[Rires]
pour assurer bien meilleure je vous le
demande jamais rien à ce que je peux
changer quand vous la santé d'ici là bas
mettez-vous la maxime est à sa place
mais des mois la passe de maxime
merci
[Applaudissements]